hi um my name is sunder Skepta from
Stockholm I heard you got the Nobel
Prize for their Big Bang Theory
wondering do you think they could have
been more big banks with some kind of
parent universes with the other Big Bang
okay thanks
Thank You Jana it's a great question but
to tell you the truth I didn't originate
the Big Bang Theory it came from a long
time ago
Einstein's equations told us about the
universe in 1916 and in 1922 Alexander
Friedmann calculated from those
equations that there should have been a
Big Bang it was done again by George
Lemaitre in 1927 and Einstein said now
that should not be but in 1929 Edwin
Hubble discovered that the universe is
expanding and so we've had the Big Bang
Theory on a firm footing ever since then
what's not been sure was the details so
I'm not claiming credit for the Big Bang
Theory but now you want to know about
other universes and parallel universes
and I'm afraid that we can't really
measure we can't tell anything from the
universe that we're in about those other
universes maybe someday we'll be able to
tell on the basis of some kind of theory
that we'll have but right now this is
something for a future work by future
generations